so anyway we have four freshmen
legislators tonight gonna talk and our
first one is Bernie Sanders who is a
representative from Vermont and
Representative Sanders is and I'm gonna
come right out and say this a socialist
hey any socialist in the Koran I think
in view of recent events that puts them
way out in front on the wave of the
future of course but because
he drives a Packard no just
because representative Sanders is not
technically a Democrat he was unable to
get into the Democratic caucus which
means he does not among other things get
the secret decoder ring
he was however able to get into the
Republican caucus they'll take anybody
and there's a no they didn't take him
either so he couldn't get in any caucus
so we're talking about a caucus free
individual here a caucus list person and
there was some speculation that this
would make representative Sanders fairly
ineffective as a legislator but he
expects to have a pretty big impact and
he's already in fact won a coveted
coveted seat on the prestigious house
plumbing Committee's Subcommittee on
urinals standardization so there's a
sense of fair play at work after all I
think in their representative Sanders
and the way this works is I'm gonna pose
a question for each of the freshmen
legislators and they all pretty much
disregard it as my hope
representative Sanders our question to
you is this as a socialist and therefore
a person committed to taking the
ill-gotten gains of the privileged
classes and redistributing them to the
oppressed are you willing to share your
reserve Capitol parking space
as I look out at this vast audience in
black and white outfits the first
question that I ask myself is what in
God's name am I doing here
let me be half serious for a moment and
thank the members of the Congress
especially the house who have been kind
enough to welcome somebody who was not a
Democrat were not a Republican and
despite the illusion I have in fact been
treated fairly and I am delighted on
that some may argue that the Banking
Committee is not all that important but
I'm delighted to be on it in any case
given the collapse of the banking system
as somebody who is the first non
Democrat or non Republican to have been
elected to the Congress for many decades
I receive a lot of mail from many people
not only in my own state of Vermont but
from all over the country as you know
there is some disillusionment with
Congress and people see me perhaps as
somebody who is a little different and
they write me letters and they say
Bernie what in fact does Congress do and
in the last week having voted on four
measures which one after vigorous debate
and many one-minute statements 423 is
zero
I do sometimes wonder what Congress does
do and then there is the question that
we get in the mail fairly often which I
have learned is of great sensitivity on
the hill and that is are these guys
really worth a hundred and twenty five
thousand dollars a year see no one is
laughing up here but that is
it's a it is an issue of great
sensitivity not as serious an issue I
gather is the issue of parking spaces
and that there are many who would vote
against the Congressional pay raise but
not give up their parking space they
have their priorities are correct
also people rights and they say is it
true that the Congress is wasting tens
and tens of billions of dollars on
frivolous activities giving the enormous
problems facing this country and people
write those letters so what I have done
is in order to answer the serious
question addressed to me tonight I have
had my administrative assistant my
legislative director we've used the
Congressional research staff very good
people that took to try to deal with
this problem for the last several weeks
and that is in fact what my office has
been doing and despite all that research
and all of that work we've been trying
to come up with something funny and we
have not been able to do it as you can
see the sweat is pouring off of my face
we have not been able to come up with
anything that's funny at all
but as the gentleman who introduced me
mentioned see how far we are away from
Washington I don't even know the
gentleman I'm sorry
obviously a household name you
but as was mentioned all of us who are
politicians hold the sacred right of a
totally ignoring the question and
answering it in any way we want to
so with that political privilege my
response to the question is this I am a
radical I am a Democratic Socialist I'm
proud of it not ashamed of it the
question was asked of me about sharing
sharing a parking space so that's much
through conservative a statement I'm
going to be bolder than that statement
and I'm going to announce tonight before
the Celeste rias and important audience
that I will do more than share my space
what I intend to do is at the right
moment at the appropriate moment to give
up my space wholly and I'm gonna tell
you what I'm gonna do this when the
United States Congress begins the
process of breaking our dependency on
the automobile when we put billions of
dollars into public transportation
rather than to the highways and roads
when we mandate that automobiles get 60
miles an hour 60 miles an hour all right
yes that's real research and development
60 miles per gallon when we have
pollution free transportation when that
happens I am prepared unequivocally to
say before you I will give up my space
thank you
the hell were they keep your space
just but just so you know I'm David
Broder
only only the united states congress
would put a socialist on the banking
committee the only industry that's
already socialized right